leur restaurant de la rue saint-vallier
est est enfermé depuis l'automne dernier
les voisins et amis ronan bonnet et
charles hugo harel se sont lancés dans
un projet impossible à réaliser dans le
tourbillon habituel d'une vie de
restaurateur celui de la réalisation
d'un court métrage d'animation en stop
motion
on a vu passer un appel de projets de la
bande vidéo sur ce petit film
qu'il fallait créer le moins de deux
minutes au sujet de la coved comme on
est on est plutôt des gens du mourre
qu'on aime bien gaulée qu'on aime bien
jouer là dedans au fil des discussions
jésus est apparu comme on est dans la
restauration évidemment c'est
naturellement au parle de ça alors on
s'est mis à l'époque on en voit jésus
dans un restaurant en tant que co vide
depuis on joue là dedans c'est
énormément de énormément de travail
énormément d'heures
ce qui nous éloigne pas tant de la
restauration faire de nombreuses heures
pour peu de bénéfices ont dix ans quand
elle existe en restauration
l'étincelle créative de charles héros
nord est venue d'un appel de projets de
la bonne vidéo
avant de vous existe depuis 40 ans notre
mandat principal c'est d'offrir des
moyens de production et de diffusion
pour des artistes qui font
essentiellement de la vidéo
l'équipe de geneviève a reçu une
centaine d'oeuvres de partout au canada
mais aussi une oeuvre de stop motion
dans l'ensemble de la programmation fait
que c'était eux donc ça a donné ce
résultat très rigolo et bien faits pour
une première oeuvre
ça nous a beaucoup plu c'est ici dans un
studio à deux pas de leur restaurant que
les deux compères ont travaillé pendant
un mois de les choisir
jésus est très à pauthe s'est peut-être
un peu ambitieux on aurait pu prendre
une autre scène que la dernière est ce
que vous avez eu la piqûre
on travaille encore sur d'autres
animations pour l'instant on fait ce
vraiment exact pour le plaisir parce
qu'on est conscient qu'un jour ça va
rouvrir se permet de se changer les
idées fille d'éviter des rares de
l'accepter du stress qui est toujours là
je fais bien en tête
on a travaillé dans le petit studio
pendant un mois on en europe de le
présenter vue de voir un peu comment les
gens vont engager ici claude et
régionale radio canada québec